I'm jazz and Lawrence and I'm a program
manager on the Xbox one engineering team
one of our biggest features is called
xbox live it's an online service that
connects gamers from all around the
world and we rely on the Internet to
make that happen
this is no easy task there are a lot of
things happening behind the scenes the
Internet is totally changing how people
interact and connect how does it work
how do the computers all across the
world actually communicate with each
other let's look at web browsing first
you open a web browser it's the app you
use to access the web pages next you
type in the web address or URL which
stands for Uniform Resource locator of
the website you want to visit like
Tumblr com hi I'm David Karp the founder
of tumblr and we're here today to talk
about how those web browsers we use
everyday actually work so you've
probably wondered what actually happens
when you type in address into your web
browser in that hit enter and it really
is about as crazy as you can imagine so
in that moment your computer starts
talking to another computer called a
server that's usually thousands of miles
away and in milliseconds your computer
asks that server for a website and that
server starts to talk back to your
computer in a language called HTTP and
HTTPS tans for hypertext Transfer
Protocol and you can kind of think of it
as the language that one computer uses
to ask another computer for a document
and it's actually really pretty
straightforward if you were to intercept
the conversation between your computer
and a web server on the Internet it's
mainly made up of something called get
requests and those are really very
simply the word get and then the name of
the document that you're requesting so
if you're trying to log in to tumblr and
load our login page all you're doing is
sending a get request to tumblr server
that says get slash login and that tells
tumblr server that
you want all of the HTML code for the
tumblr login page so HTML stands for
hypertext markup language and you can
think of that as the language that you
use to tell a web browser how to make a
page look so if you think about
something like Wikipedia which is really
just a big simple document and hTML is
the language that you use to make that
title big and bold to make the font the
right font to link certain text to
certain other pages to make some text
bold to make some text italic to put an
image in the middle of the page to align
image to the right to align the image to
the left the text of a webpage is
included directly in the HTML but other
parts images or videos are separate
files with their own URLs that need to
be requested the browser sends separate
HTTP requests for each of these and
displays them as they arrive if a web
page has a lot of different images each
of them causes a separate HTTP request
and the page loads slower now sometimes
when you browse the web you're not just
requesting pages with get requests
sometimes you send information like when
you fill out a form or type a search
query your browser sends this
information in plain text to the web
server using an HTTP POST request so
let's say you log in to tumblr well the
first thing you do is you make a post
request that is a post to tumblr login
page that has some data attached to it
it has your email address it has your
password that goes to tumblr server
tumblr server figures out that okay your
David it sends a webpage back to your
browser that says success logged in as
David but along with that web page it
also attaches a little bit of invisible
cookie data that your browser sees and
knows to save and that's really
important because it's really the only
way that a website can remember who you
are and all that cookie data really is
is it an ID card for tumblr it's a
number that identifies you as David and
your web browser holds on to that number
and then the next time you refresh
tumblr the next time you go to tumblr
calm your web browser knows to
automatically attach that ID number with
the request that it sends over to tumblr
server so now tumblr server sees the
request coming from your browser sees
the ID number and knows okay this is a
request from david now the Internet is
completely open all of its connections
are shared and information is sent in
plain text this makes it possible for
hackers to snoop on any personal
information that you send over the
Internet
but safe web sites prevent this by
asking your web browser to communicate
on a secure channel using something
called Secure Sockets Layer and its
successor transport layer security you
can think of SSL and TLS as a layer
security wrapped around your
communications to protect them from
snooping or tampering SSL and TLS are
active when you see the little lock that
appears in your browser address bar next
to the HTTPS the HTTP protocols ensure
that your HTTP requests are secure and
protected when a web site asks your
browser to engage in a secure connection
it first provides a digital certificate
which is like an official ID card
proving that it's the website it claims
to be digital certificates are published
by certificate authorities which are
trusted entities that verify the
identities of websites and issue
certificates for them just like a
government can issue IDs or passports
now if a website tries to start a secure
connection without a properly issued
digital certificate your browser will
warn you that's the basics of web
browsing the part of the internet we see
day-to-day to summarize HTTP and DNS
manage the sending and receiving of HTML
media files or anything on the web what
makes this possible under the hood our
tcp/ip and router networks that break
down and transfer information in small
packets those packets themselves are
made up of binary sequences of ones and
zeros that are
some through electric wires fiber-optic
cables and wireless networks fortunately
once you've learned how one layer of the
Internet works you can rely on it
without remembering all the details and
we can trust that all those layers will
work together to successfully deliver
information at scale and with
reliability